This is C. botulinum.
It's a bacterium that can
produce one of the world's
most lethal substances.
It lives in lots of places including soil,
pollen, dust, and also in honey.
So why haven't you died from
eating this sweet treat?
Because you're not a baby.
As C. botulinum grows, it
produces botulinum toxin.
It's the same stuff used in Botox,
but Botox has an extremely
low dose compared to infected food.
In large amounts,
the toxin would attack
your nervous system,
causing the illness known as botulism,
which can lead to
paralysis and even death.
And since C. botulinum is so
common in our environment,
researchers believe that
bees pick it up on their way
to the hive where they produce honey.
One study found C. botulinum bacteria
in about 8% of honey samples.
But before you purge your
pantry, consider this.
Normally when we encounter
C. Botulinum, like in honey,
it's dormant.
In this sleepy state, it
can't produce the toxin.
Even if you ate it.
Unless, of course, you're
less than 1 year old.
When C. botulinum enters
a baby's large intestine,
it comes alive because
unlike children and adults,
babies less than 1 year
old haven't been eating
real solid foods.
They've been drinking milk.
But when babies are
around 4 to 6 months old,
they stop drinking human
milk, and they start eating
other foods that they've never had before.
As a result, their gut
microbes change very abruptly,
and it's during this transition
period in the baby's gut
that the lethal C. botulinum
bacteria are free to grow
and produce the toxin.
As the toxin enters
the baby's bloodstream,
it blocks the ability of
motor nerves to release
acetylcholine, a chemical messenger
that sends nerve signals to muscles.
As a result, the baby starts
to lose control of muscles
and appears tired and floppy.
And as more toxin enters
the bloodstream, the muscles
that control swallowing
and breathing stop working.
Fortunately, infant
botulism is not very common,
and infant botulism due
to honey is even rarer.
Fewer than 100 cases
occur in the US each year,
and while it's difficult
to pinpoint the source
of the bacterium in many cases,
experts think that honey accounts for 15%.
So it's important that if
your infant shows signs
of weakness, you take them to be evaluated
by medical professionals immediately.
In some cases, doctors can administer
an effective antitoxin,
but it can take babies
weeks or a month to recover.
The FDA recommends waiting
until your baby's first birthday
to feed them honey or any products
that are filled with or dipped in honey.